fue muy evidente el alivio entre los
políticos alemanes que reaccionaron a la
elección de joe biden como próximo
presidente de eeuu después de cuatro
años muy difíciles en las relaciones
bilaterales en las que el presidente de
eeuu donald trump criticó desde las
políticas comerciales de alemania hasta
los gastos en defensa es claro que el
gobierno alemán espera un nuevo comienzo
como dijo el ministro de exteriores hay
como más un nuevo acuerdo
la idea es obviamente fortalecer las
relaciones transatlánticas la canciller
alemana angela merkel en un mensaje de
felicitación también expresó su deseo de
trabajar con el nuevo gobierno de joe
biden y es que no hay que olvidar que
angela merkel conoce muy bien a byd en
las relaciones entre merkel y el
entonces gobierno del presidente barack
obama eran particularmente fuertes y yo
va a tener a por supuesto el
vicepresidente de obama
hay que esperar que los problemas
actuales entre alemania y eeuu vayan a
desaparecer simplemente porque hay un
nuevo gobierno pero las autoridades en
este país si esperan que cambie el tono
y que la lección de joe biden puede
darle un nuevo impulso a una relación
que es particularmente importante para
alemania